Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number where
you can reach me at two one nine two David
P..
I also am launching I mentioned yesterday
that we are new on this platform called Bitcoin
Clout.
You can find me there at David Pakman dot
com slash bit clout.
What are going to be my top 20 holders are
going to have a system to directly message
me on the platform and I will write you back.
So I am actually establishing a system.
If you don't like the voicemail, if you don't
like being like some of our trolls leaving
10, 12 voicemails a night into the void, follow
me on bit cloud at David Pakman dot com slash
bit cloud.
My top 20 coin holders will have a function
to directly direct message me.
OK, here is our friend from Argentina who
lives in Miami.
Unfortunately, she has fallen for an anti
vaccine talking point.
Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, this is an interesting
video from Miami, right?
There's is something that I, I'm worried about
and I don't hear anybody talking about people
who got vaccinated in December.
Yes.
My you may not be protected anymore because
all they can guarantee is that.
Is the protection lasted at least six months,
they suppose that maybe it will last more,
but they don't know.
And I don't hear about any plan of how to
handle that,
Speaker 1: so two parts, first of all, you
have to understand something.
When there was an announcement made that said
immunity lasts for at least six months, what
they meant was we've been following people
for six months and so far, immunity hasn't
declined.
Then there was a seventh month and it looks
like it's now seven months, what they mean
by that is the vaccines being relatively new.
All we can say is they work for the period
of time that people that we've been putting
in trials have been vaccinated.
There is no reason to think that after seven
months or eight months or nine months, immunity
will go down.
The belief among epidemiologists and and immunologists
right now is that immunity against those original
vaccines for which the original vaccines were
tuned likely lasts at least years.
Now, if the virus changes, then the effective
efficacy will be diminished.
But by the fall, Moderna and Pfizer are expecting
to have Booster's tuned to the variants.
So when the headline came out only six months
of immunity, it was widely used by antibiotics.
People to say it only works for six months.
Now what we know is it's been six months and
there's no decline in immunity so far.
And we'll look at it after seven and we'll
look at it after eight and we'll look at it
after nine.
OK, that's all that means.
Nothing to be worried about for the time being.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at Joint Zachmanoglou.